tom en parlant de transparence notre
équipe d' enquête a découvert que
philippe couillard pendant qu'il
travaillait en arabie saoudite a procédé
pendant huit ans un compte à l'étranger
dans l'île de jaws est considéré comme
un paradis fiscal
rien d'illégal mais une information de
plus dans ce portrait financier que
souhaitaient justement complet le chef
libéral alain gravel en jouant depuis
quelques jours la carte de la
transparence fait des couilles arani
avoir eu un compte bancaire à l'étranger
en arabie comme tous les gens qui
étaient là j'étais non risque donc j'ai
placé mes avoirs à l'époque dans une
banque qu'à l'étranger
quand je suis revenu j'ai réunira pas
trier ça chez nous je me cherchais de
maisons s'est réinstallé et ce qui
restait de payer d'impôt dessus
ce que n'a pas dit monsieur couillard
c'est que je compte était dans l'île de
jersey située entre l'angleterre et la
france inscrits jusqu'à récemment sur la
liste noire des paradis fiscaux
monsieur couillard a ni par la voix d'un
porte-parole avoir possédé ce compte
bancaire de 1992 à 2000 mais il a refusé
que nous l'interrogions sur ce compte
son porte parole a souligné que monsieur
couillard il ya déposé six cent mille
dollars provenant de ses revenus alors
qu'il pratiquait la neurochirurgie en
arabie saoudite de 1992 à 1996 qu'il est
vrai qu'il n'a payé aucun impôt sur
cette somme mais que c'était tout à fait
légale puisqu'il avait à l'époque rompu
tous ses liens avec le canada
à son retour au pays monsieur guillard a
fait une déclaration volontaire sur
l'existence de ce compte
il a payé des impôts mais uniquement sur
les intérêts comme l'exigé la loi
s'il a choisi l'île de jersey c'est
qu'ils cherchaient avant tout à faire
affaire avec une banque canadienne
mais des spécialistes que nous avons
consultés demeure sceptique sur cette
raison puisque monsieur couillard aurait
pu pouvait effectivement déposer son
argent ben finalement dans toutes les
institutions financières de la terre
s'il choisit ici c'est tous les agrès
que ça lui apporter il n'apprécie pas la
craie que ça apporte du jury
surtout à cette époque là c'est le
secret bancaire puisque le secret
bancaire était absolue à jersey il n'y a
aucune possibilité de vérifier si le
montant de 5000 $ est bien celui qui a
transité
mais nous n'avons aucune preuve du
contraire des spécialistes consultés
nous indique qu'il n'y a rien d'illégal
à faire affaire dans un paradis fiscal
même si certains s'interrogent sur
l'acceptabilité sociale dit détenir un
compte de banque
alain gravel radio canada montréal